ANNA KATE HICKS: My
name is Anna Kate Hicks,
and I'm a freshman
from Cincinnati, Ohio.
It is my pleasure this afternoon
to introduce our speaker.
Richard B. Gunderman is
Chancellor's Professor
of Radiology, Pediatrics,
Medical Education, Philosophy,
Liberal Arts, Philanthropy,
and Medical Humanities
and Health Studies at
Indiana University, where
he's also the John A. Campbell
Professor of Radiology.
He also serves as Bicentennial
Professor at Indiana University
and as President of the Medical
Staff Executive at IU Health.
He received his AB from Wabash
College and his M.D. and PhD
from the University of Chicago.
He's a 10-time recipient of
the Indiana University Trustees
Teaching Award.
And in 2012, he received
the Glaser Teaching Award
from the Association of
American Medical Colleges.
Dr. Gunderman is the author of
numerous articles and 15 books,
including We Make a
Life by What We Give,
Tesla, Contagion,
and Marie Curie.
Please help me in
welcoming Dr. Gunderman.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD B. GUNDERMAN:
Good afternoon.
It's a treat to be here.
I didn't know what I was doing
when I applied to college,
but I stumbled into a very
good all-male liberal arts
college in Northwest
Central Indiana called
Wabash College, actually an
all-male institution, which
was not an enticement to me.
But I had a chance to meet
terrific faculty members who
opened up intellectual horizons
and professional opportunities
that I don't think would have
even occurred to me, let alone
seemed feasible.
And then, as AK
indicated, thanks to them,
I ended up at the
University of Chicago,
pursued fairly conventional
medical studies,
but was in a program called
the Medical Scientist Training
Program, and got to study in
the Committee on Social Thought.
So I went to an undergraduate
liberal arts institution.
And if you read the
description of the Committee
on Social Thought at the
University of Chicago,
at least at the
time I was there,
it described itself
as, among other things,
providing a liberal education
at the graduate level.
So I'm a person who's
had the opportunity
to pursue a liberal arts
education for a long time
at a few institutions.
And I'm delighted to bring
some of that learning
today to this talk, which
is on the importance
of the liberal arts.
But we'll be focusing
on a physician's view.
Would a physician have
anything useful to say
about the liberal arts,
and equally interesting,
does the liberal
arts have anything
to contribute to medicine.
So let me start
out by correcting
what could be a
misapprehension that
might flow from the title
of this presentation.
In my view, the
liberal arts aren't
really separable from medicine,
nor are the liberal arts
preparation for medicine.
In fact, the liberal
arts and medicine
are largely coextensive.
They would overlap a
lot on a Venn diagram,
at least if we see them clearly.
To thrive as a reader or a
teacher or a writer of books,
one must attend to many of
the same things that command
a physician's attention.
To care well for patients
requires the same habits
of ear, mind, and heart that the
liberal arts aim to cultivate.
In both spheres, it takes
years, perhaps decades, perhaps
even a lifetime, to
learn to perceive,
understand, and respond with
compassion and imagination
to the human reality before us.
Both spheres require the
cultivation of essentially
the same human excellences.
Consider a story
shared with me by one
of my favorite medical students,
whose name is Muhammad.
Muhammad left the hospital
one dank winter night.
And as he walked
to his bicycle, he
saw a large mountain of a
man carrying three bags,
approaching him on the sidewalk.
The man's intentions
were unclear.
Did he, for example,
plan to ask for money?
Did he intend to
take it by force?
But Muhammad resisted
the temptation
to cross to the other side.
The distance between
them soon closed.
And soon, the man's
chest was just
inches from Muhammad's face.
The man said, do you work here?
I need to get to
the emergency room.
Muhammad replied, It's
a few blocks away.
The man asked, could
you drive me there?
Actually, said Muhammad,
I rode my bike today.
The man took off his
backpack, opened it,
and handed Muhammad a blanket.
He said, Here, take this.
It's too cold to be out biking.
Then the man said please
don't leave me here alone.
I'm blind.
If you want to learn, teach,
or write about the importance
of not jumping to conclusions,
not writing people off
based on how they look
or talk or even smell,
you could do worse than to read
a letter the greatest physician
poet in the English
language, John Keats,
wrote on a dank
winter night in 1817
to his brothers, George and Tom.
Considering the
close relationship
of truth and beauty
in King Lear,
Keats describes what he
calls negative capability.
Negative capability--
the ability
to be in uncertainties,
mysteries, and doubts
without any irritable reaching
after fact and reason.
When we encounter something
we're not sure about--
an idea, a new way of
thinking, a large mountain
of a man carrying three bags--
Keats counsels us to
observe, to be patient,
to dwell in uncertainty,
and to avoid resorting
to predetermined categories.
His counsel to patients
shines all the more brightly
when we consider that Keats
himself died of tuberculosis
at the age of only 25 years.
Keats is like Socrates.
If we explain every
new thing we encounter
in terms of what
we already know,
we'll never learn anything new.
We'll keep explaining everything
as A or B, A or not A,
and never recognize that
there's also a C, a D, and an E.
Socrates was likened
by his contemporaries
to a torpedo fish or a
stingray, which jolts
its prey, disorienting it.
In the dialogues of
Plato, Minos wants
to enrich his cocktail
party repertoire
by quoting Socrates'
accounts of the virtues.
Simmias and Cebes want to
know why a person should
keep striving to be
good even though death
comes to the virtuous
and vicious alike.
But before they can
gain real insight,
Socrates' interlocutors
must first
set aside, at least for a time,
what they think they know.
If they're going to
gain new insight,
they must first admit
that they do not know.
Then they can cast off anew
in the pursuit of wisdom.
They must drink liberally
from that most ironic
of wellsprings,
negative capability.
Reviewing video
recordings of hundreds
of physician-patient
encounters, a colleague of mine
determined that
we physicians can
listen to patients for how many
seconds until we interrupt?
The answer is 18.
We, that is, physicians, in the
words of Sergeant Joe Friday,
we want just the facts.
That is just the parts of
the story that fit neatly
into our preconceptions.
And we wanted them to be
conveyed as efficiently
as possible.
How easily we forget that the
patient is sharing with us more
than the clues to a diagnosis.
The patient is sharing
a human experience,
one that deserves to
be treated as more
than a mere means to an end.
Paraphrasing Kant,
we must never resolve
to treat any story as
a means to confirming
our own preconceptions only,
but always, at the same time,
as a source of
illumination in itself.
What we need, whether taking
a history from a patient
or reading one of Keats' odes or
Plato's dialogues, what we need
is the capacity to listen
patiently, to hear what
is being said, and to
allow the story itself
to tell us what it means
rather than making the story
tell us what we expect
or want to hear.
Consider another story,
this one shared with me
by a priest, whose name
I can no longer recall.
As part of his clinical
pastoral education,
he was assigned to make
monthly home visits
to a patient named Shirley.
Shirley was an elderly
woman who lived alone.
At every visit, Shirley
would talk virtually nonstop,
and her visitor soon
realized he couldn't
get in a word edgewise.
Feeling that he was not
contributing anything,
the priest began to dread
his visits with Shirley.
She did all the talking,
and he felt useless.
Almost as soon as
he sat down, he
found himself looking
for opportunities
to say that he needed to go.
Some time later,
after Shirley died,
the priest received a
letter from his supervisor
in which Shirley went on
at length about how much
his visits had meant to her.
The priest thought
he was doing nothing,
but by being there and
listening to Shirley,
he was providing
exactly what she needed.
In this, the priest
is recalling a lesson
of the greatest physician
dramatist in world literature,
Anton Chekhov.
Chekhov practiced medicine
all his adult life, right up
to his premature death
from tuberculosis
at the age of 44 years.
In his short story,
"Yearning," we
are treated to a ringside
seat on human loneliness.
A poor cab man, a taxi driver,
we might say, named Iona,
tries to share with his fares
what is weighing heavily
on his heart.
His son, who should
have succeeded him,
has recently died of
a febrile illness,
leaving the old man all alone.
First Iona reaches out
to a military officer
intent on reaching
his destination
as efficiently as possible.
Then he reaches out to a group
of three drunken young men
looking for a good time.
Then he reaches out
to a fellow cab man.
And finally, he's left
with his own mare,
who seems to listen
as she munches on hay.
He says to her, now, suppose
you had a little colt.
And suppose that little colt,
all at once, went and died.
You'd be sorry, wouldn't you?
The practice of medicine, like
the study of great literature,
reminds us that sometimes
what we human beings most need
is someone to listen,
someone just to be there.
Recall the Book of Job.
Job, the greatest
man in all the East,
righteous and upright before
God, has lost everything--
his property, his
children, his own health.
He's fallen as far as a human
being can possibly descend.
And he sits in ashes, scratching
himself with pot shards.
When his three friends,
Eliphaz, Bildad, and Zophar
arrive on the scene, they
resist the temptation
to launch into sophisticated,
philosophical, and theological
explanations or justifications
for what has befallen Job.
They simply sit down silently
at their friend's side,
remaining there for seven
days and seven nights.
To be sure, they will
later stray from this path,
but their first impulse is
their best, simply to be there.
We can't fix poverty, ignorance,
injustice, or terminal illness.
We certainly cannot
fix mortality.
But we can recognize our
part and play it well.
Not the part of the immortal
and ageless gods, whose lives
in Homer sometimes
resemble nothing
more than daytime
television drama,
but the human part, the part of
Achilles and Priam and Hector,
whose only hope
for coming to life
lies in recognition of
their shared humanity.
Achilles must see
his father in Priam,
and Priam must see
his son in Achilles.
Achilles must see
himself in Hector,
and Hector must see himself
loaded up in battle gear
through the eyes of
his terrified son.
It is our capacity to
be there, in the sense
of occupying someone
else's space,
inhabiting their reality
that constitutes one
of humanity's saving graces.
When we see through
the eyes of another,
we gain a more complete
vision of the human situation.
Like many academic hospitals
and health systems,
in Indianapolis,
we have a program
called No One Dies Alone.
Its purpose is not
to sustain a failing
pulse or respiration
for as long as possible
but to recognize the
inevitability and even
the appropriateness of dying
and trying to enable people
to die as well as possible.
There are good deaths
and bad deaths,
and often one of the
physician's most urgent missions
is to recognize and
respect this difference
and work on behalf
of patient and family
to midwife a good death.
This means addressing one of the
most common fears I encounter
with patients about dying--
dying alone.
Volunteers simply sit by the
bedside of dying patients.
Sometimes they hear nothing
but aginal respirations,
but other times,
they hear stories.
And sometimes the stories
are rather like those
of Chekhov's cab man.
When they listen with eyes
and ears and heart open,
they are granted the opportunity
to answer the human call.
Consider another story,
this one shared with me
by the daughter of a
man deceased long ago.
In the first half
of the 20th century,
Otis Bowen M.D. Grew
up the son of a teacher
in Northwest Indiana.
Otis Bowen's father had
eight grades of students
in a one-room school, where he
functioned as teacher, janitor,
and nurse, carrying wood and
water to the schoolhouse,
and earning $2.50 a day.
Bowen decided to
follow a different path
and become a physician.
To get money for college
and medical school,
he hoed potatoes
for $0.10 an hour.
He milked a cow morning
and night for $0.10 a day.
He mowed grass for $0.25 a
yard, $0.35 for large yards.
And he shucked oats
and wheat for $1 a day.
Bowen persevered,
eventually graduating
from the Indiana University
School of Medicine,
serving in the Pacific
Theater in World War II,
setting up his own
practice in rural Indiana,
delivering 3,000 babies over
the course of his career,
including five
generations in one family,
and attending all of
his patients' funerals.
He also won election to
the state legislature,
served as Speaker of
the House of the Indiana
House of Representatives, became
the first governor in Indiana
to serve eight
consecutive years,
and then served as US Secretary
of Health and Human Services
during the Reagan
administration.
Otis Bowen was known as Doc
throughout his adult life.
And over the course
of his career,
he found himself devoting
more and more of his time
to public service
and less to medicine.
Once, though, relatively
late in his life, a woman
came up to him.
She reminded him
of the days when,
much earlier in
his medical career,
he had served as coroner
of Marshall County.
She called to his mind a case he
had been summoned to one day--
a middle-aged man killed
in an industrial accident.
She reminded him
that he had performed
the autopsy on that man.
And she told him that the
man on whom he had performed
the autopsy was her father.
Otis Bowen recalled the
event in vivid detail,
describing what had happened and
how deeply it had touched him.
And as he talked, tears
streamed down his face.
In recalling this encounter
with the mortal remains
of another human
being, I suspect
Bowen had encountered
his father's mortality,
his own mortality, the
mortality of humankind.
Bowen had developed
personal relationships
with famous people, including
US presidents, vice presidents,
speakers of the house,
senate majority leaders.
He moved easily
among the wealthy,
who sought to curry the favor
of government officials.
He achieved unprecedented
political success
in his home state and
assumed responsibility
for the largest department
in the federal government.
Otis Bowen was, in
short, a big deal,
and his calls would be taken
by the most famous, richest,
and powerful people
in our country.
But what really moved him,
what brought him to tears,
was not seeing his
name on the front page
or securing a financial
windfall or winning high office.
What really touched him
was an encounter with two
human beings--
one long dead, and the other
the decedent's offspring.
It was akin to the encounter
between Achilles and Priam.
Such encounters are the
distinctive privilege
of physicians, who
are called upon
not merely to pronounce
death or assign it a cause
but also to witness it
and feel its significance.
We adopt disguises,
we human beings.
We load ourselves up with
titles, riches, authority.
Yet no matter who one
of us happens to be
or would like respecters of
persons to think that we are,
underneath, we are all human.
Even the most famous,
richest, and most powerful
people are made
of the same flesh
and blood as the weakest, the
poorest, and the most obscure.
They too wailed as infants,
suckled at their mother's
breast, bounced on
their father's knee,
railed during school years
against the cafeteria food,
got butterflies in their stomach
on their first date, debated
the care of aging parents, and
before long, found themselves
the subject of debate.
Our costumes
present one reality.
But to examine us, to know
us, and to care for us,
the physician must
allow such layers
to fall away until the
unadorned human being underneath
is revealed.
The physician's job is
not to dismiss or condemn.
The physician's job
is to know and care.
Much the same could
be said for the job
of the poet, the
philosopher, the theologian.
Consider one of the greatest
novellas ever penned,
Leo Tolstoy's The
Death of Ivan Ilyich.
In it, a successful
lawyer and judge
who has devoted his life
to moving up the ladder,
maintaining a decorous
life, and doing
what is expected
by those above him,
he develops a serious illness.
As he wrestles with
his own mortality,
he discovers that
he's not only dying
from what I presumed to be a
cancer of the digestive system,
he discovers that he's been
dying his whole life, even
during his prime, because
he has never really lived.
In fact, he has
known less and less
of life's meaning and purpose
with each passing year.
The things that
brought him pleasure--
house, car, job title,
wealth, prestige--
they no longer
bring him pleasure.
And he feels himself caught
up in a web of deception
from which he has no means
of extricating himself.
It's not merely that no one will
tell him what he wants to hear,
but that no one will
utter the truth.
You don't want to end up in
the position of Ivan Ilyich,
who in the last days of his
life finds himself tortured
by a thought that he
cannot get out of its mind.
It occurred to Ivan Ilyich that
what had appeared perfectly
impossible before,
namely that he has not
spent his life as he should have
done, might after all be true.
It occurred to him that his
scarcely perceptible attempts
to struggle against
what was considered good
by the most highly
placed of his associates,
he had immediately suppressed.
What he had been
looking for was false.
His life had been based
on a false premise.
His professional duties and the
whole arrangement of his life
and of his family and all his
social and official interests
might all have been false.
He tried to defend
those things to himself
and suddenly felt the weakness
of what he was defending.
There was nothing to defend.
Ivan Ilyich is truly lost.
He's positioned himself
at the periphery
of the human solar system.
He's been chasing
after shiny things
while turning his back on
the true source of warmth
and light.
His physicians, like him,
have expunged everything
real and human from their
purely technical practice,
and they're not much help.
They debate diagnoses
and treatment regimens
while the human being under
their care withers away.
Yet they could help.
They could recognize that
Ivan Ilyich is dying.
They could treat him not
as a malfunctioning organ,
but as a human being, a creature
who, regardless of his age,
needs someone to be near, to
talk, to listen, and to care.
Ivan Ilyich is a reminder
that the best things in life
are priceless.
That they are almost never
represented on resumes or CVs,
and that we cannot
take them with us.
Yet we can share them with
others, and in so doing,
not diminish but actually
enrich our own supply.
For it is in sharing,
something Ivan Ilyich
has never done, that the
things that really matter
come to life.
These are the physician's
most precious resources--
time to spend where the
return on investment
is greatest, attention to devote
to the things that matter most,
beauty, which lies all around
us if we have eyes to see
and ears to hear, truth, a
glimpse into the way things
really are, and
love, the capacity
to share a moment or a
lifetime with another person
in grieving or
rejoicing with them.
Ivan Ilyich is not a protagonist
to admire or emulate.
He is a portrait of a
human life misspent,
a reminder that even those
with their fingers on the pulse
of life itself, physicians and
other health professionals,
can become dangerously
distracted from what
most deserves our attention.
Diagnosing, prognosing, curing,
palliating, comforting--
these activities work in service
to a deeper human reality,
one that reveals a
glimpse of itself
every time a baby is
born or a person dies.
We must do our jobs well but
always mindful of a deeper
reality, a thread that Ivan
Ilyich completely lost contact
with.
Consider another story.
A woman with advanced
head and neck cancer
was scheduled to undergo
radical surgery the next day.
She had led a life that
many on her medical team
did not approve of.
After the team visited her
room and obtained her informed
consent, they prepared to exit.
But before they did so,
she handed each one of them
a small plastic bag
containing a mustard seed.
The members of the
team turned and exited
in orders of seniority.
As the attending surgeon did
so, he dropped the mustard seed
in the trash.
Then the head and neck
fellow followed suit,
discarding the gift.
Then the senior surgery
resident, and so on, right down
the line, until the third
year medical student,
the junior person on
the team, left the room.
But this time, instead
of disposing of it,
the most junior team member
tucked the little plastic bag
into the pocket
of his white coat.
His act presents
us with questions.
What did the patient
mean by handing
the members of the
team plastic bags
with mustard seeds in them?
What did they mean to
her, and what did they
mean to the team members?
And why did the medical
student, the most junior person
on the team, break ranks and
keep his mustard seed gift?
Thomas Browne, the
greatest physician essayist
in the English language, knew
the answer to that question.
In his masterpiece, The
Religion of a Physician,
composed in the 17th
century, he reminds us
of truths that have not dimmed
a lumen in the long interval
since.
Those centuries saw a lot, since
the 17th century in medicine.
Since then we've seen the
discovery or introduction
of blood cells,
bacteria, the use
of citrus fruits
to prevent scurvy,
vaccination against smallpox,
inhalation anesthesia,
the stethoscope, antisepsis
to prevent infection, the germ
theory, X-rays,
penicillin, blood typing,
electrocardiography,
chemotherapy for cancer,
the double helical
structure of DNA,
organ transplantation, CT
scanners, MRI scanners,
the eradication of smallpox
from the face of the Earth,
kidney dialysis, and vaccination
as a means of preventing
cancer.
Wow.
There was a lot
that Thomas Browne
didn't know that we do know.
And yet Thomas Browne
glimpsed some eternal truths
that we all too
easily lose sight of.
Consider Browne's
humanity, which
is to say his
charity, as expressed
in The Religion of a Physician.
"It is a barbarous part of
inhumanity to add unto any
afflicted party's misery or
endeavor to multiply in any man
a passion whose single nature
is already above his patient's.
This was the greatest
affliction of Job,
and those oblique
ex-postulations of his friends
a deeper injury than the
downright blows of the Devil.
It is not the tears of our own
eyes only, but of our friends
also that do exhaust the
current of our sorrows, which
falling into many streams,
run more peaceably
and is contented with
a narrower channel.
It is an act within
the power of charity
to translate a passion out
of one breast into another
and to divide a sorrow
almost out of itself.
For an affliction,
like a dimension,
may be so divided, as if
not indivisible, at least
to become insensible.
Now, with my friend I desire
not to share or participate
but to engross his sorrows,
that by making them
mine own I may more
easily discuss them.
For in mine own reason and
within myself I can command
that which I cannot entreat
without myself and within
the circle of another."
The liberal arts don't
merely inform the practice
of the physician Thomas Browne.
The physician Thomas
Browne does not merely
draw on the liberal arts.
It would be truer to say that
Thomas Browne is a perfection
of the liberal arts.
And it is through
his care of patients
that this perfection
has taken place.
The first Hippocratic
injunction is not merely a rule
that he chooses to follow,
but a habit deeply ingrained
in the fibers of his being--
do no harm.
To reach out with compassion
to those who are suffering
has become second nature to him.
He knows, as he knows
that an apple will fall,
that if he shares another's
pain, the burden of that pain
will be lightened.
He is not merely recognizing,
acknowledging, classifying,
forecasting, and treating
another's affliction.
He is encompassing it.
By giving others the opportunity
to share what they usually
keep to themselves,
he creates conditions
under which trust can thrive.
He is finding within the
practice of an ancient healing
art not merely an opportunity
to divert the path of a disease,
but to forge a friendship.
Browne is most assuredly
a physician, a gentleman,
and a scholar, but he is, above
all, a human being in full.
Consider a much
more recent portrait
of the physician
as a friend of man,
that of the pseudonymous Dr.
John Sassall in John Berger
and Jean Mohr's 1967
book, A Fortunate Man.
Sassall practices in Western
England's Forest of Dean.
And, in many ways,
he differs sharply
from the people and the
community he cares for.
He's different in birthplace,
socioeconomic class,
educational attainment,
life experience.
Sassall knows that in order
to care for his neighbors,
he must become one of
them, and he does this
by building something.
There's a castle
moat in town that
has long been used as a dump.
Sassall proposes that they
turn it into a garden.
He gets himself named the
chair of the garden committee,
but he defers to
his neighbors, who
know a good deal more than he
about how to design and build
a garden.
Eventually, after years
of effort, during which he
has labored at their side
most summer evenings,
the garden is complete.
A neighbor, Sassall
realizes, is one
with whom I have labored side
by side, working toward a shared
vision.
Not primarily through medical
care, but through shared work,
he ceases to be merely for
them and lives among them,
becoming one of them.
Cicero famously said, if you
have a garden and a library,
you have just about everything.
Thomas Browne builds a library.
John Sassall builds a garden.
But the library is not just
a place of instruction,
and the garden is
not just a source
of nourishing vegetables.
In Brown's essays, we
find objects every bit
as rich and beautiful
as a juicy red tomato.
And in Sassall's garden lie
lessons that every physician,
and to a lesser extent,
every human being,
is called upon to learn.
In both cases, we
must put asunder
the things that should
be separated and meld
the things that
should be joined,
all in the service of
healing, of making whole.
Browne's prose and
Sassall's garden
teach us the
meaning of patience,
discipline, nurturance,
resilience, and hope.
They teach us that wisdom
is not so much propositional
as experiential, and that
the essential experience
is to recognize ourselves
as part of something
larger, deeper,
and more enduring,
something we can either
ignore or embrace, thwart
or cultivate.
At some point, the
most fitting response
is not to beat our breasts,
but to bow our heads.
To see the connection between
the liberal arts and medicine,
we can turn to no
finer recent guide
than the greatest American
physician poet, William Carlos
Williams.
In a chapter of
his autobiography,
called The Practice,
Williams shows us
that doctoring and writing,
medicine and the liberal arts,
are twin aspects of
the same calling.
Of his encounters
with patients, he
writes, "I lost myself in the
very properties of their minds.
For the moment, at
least, I actually
became them, whoever
they should be,
so that when I detached
myself from them
at the end of a half an hour
of intense concentration
over some illness which
was affecting them,
it was as though I were
reawakening from a sleep.
For the moment, I
myself did not exist.
Nothing of myself affected me.
As a consequence, I
came back to myself, as
from any other sleep, rested.
They naively asked,
how do you do it?
How can you carry on an
active practice like that
and at the same time
find time to write?
You must be superhuman.
You must have, at
the very least,
the energy of two people.
But they do not grasp that
one occupation complements
the other, that they are
two parts of the whole,
that it is not two jobs at
all, that one rests the man
if the other fatigues him.
Forget writing.
It's a trivial matter.
But day in and day out, when
the inarticulate patient
struggles to lay himself
bare for you, or with nothing
more than a boil on his back
is so caught off balance
that he reveals a whole
community's way of thought,
a man is suddenly seized
again with the desire
to speak of the underground
stream which, for a moment,
has just come up under surface.
We catch a glimpse of
something, from time
to time, which shows us
that a presence has just
brushed past us,
some rare thing, just
when the smiling little
Italian woman has left us.
For a moment, we are dazzled.
What was that?
We can't name it.
We know it never gets into
any recognizable avenue
of expression.
Men will be long dead before
they can have so much as ever
approached it.
Whole lives are spent in
the tremendous affairs
of daily events without ever
approaching the great insights
I see every day.
We begin to see that the
underlying meaning of all
they want to tell us and have
always failed to communicate
is the poem, the poem
which their whole lives are
being lived to realize.
No one will believe it.
And it is the actual words
as we hear them spoken,
under all circumstances
which contain it.
It is actually there,
in the life before us,
every minute that
we are listening,
a rarest element not
in our imaginations,
but there, there in fact.
It is that essence which is
hidden in the very words which
are going in at our ears and
from which we must recover
underlying meaning as
realistically as we recover
metal out of ore."
And here we come to the end.
If you care about money,
perhaps go into business.
If you care about power,
perhaps go into politics.
If you care about fame,
become an entertainer.
But if, as Dostoevsky puts
it, you want not millions,
but answers to your
questions, and especially
if you want to learn to
pose even better questions,
if, in other words, what you
want above all is the truth,
consider a career in
the health professions.
The truth lies not in
textbooks or Journal articles
and certainly not in the answers
to standardized, high-stakes
multiple choice tests questions.
The truth lies in the words
of human beings stripped
bare, confronted
by life and death,
ordinary people,
who sometimes quite
unknowingly capture
what most needs
to be said in words
of unsurpassed beauty.
The liberal arts are
meant to set us free,
but they do so by
means of the true.
And to be free we must
encounter the truth.
It is perhaps in
medicine, more than just
about any other calling,
that the truth of humankind
is exposed.
As Tolstoy said, "We find
truth as we purify gold--
not by adding to it,
but by washing away all
that is not gold.
At its best, the
practice of medicine
represents both the calling
and the consummation
for which the liberal
arts have always yearned."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNA KATE HICKS: Thank
you, Dr. Gunderman.
We now have time for Q&A,
so if you have questions--
AUDIENCE: --their patients
within the clinical setting.
And you were talking about
how a physician, according
to Thomas Browne, how
they should encompass what
they are going through in
order to actually have a better
relationship with that patient.
So I just wondering,
what can physicians
do, since they have such a
limited time in their practice,
to really connect
with their patients?
RICHARD B. GUNDERMAN:
The 18 seconds is not
how long we have for a clinical
encounter with a patient,
but the amount of time
we listen to a patient,
on average, before
we interrupt them.
But the spirit of your
question is bang on.
The amount of time we have per
patient has been declining.
Maybe an office visit was once
20 minutes, then 15 minutes,
now 12 minutes.
What will it take to
shave it down to eight?
And it's not just a matter
of diminishing time.
It's a matter of distraction.
Because when you
encounter a patient,
you're encouraged
not only to listen
to the patient, maybe not
even primarily to listen
to the patient, but to
be thinking about things
like an ICD-10 code.
Anybody know what
an ICD-10 code is?
ICD-10 stands for the
International Classification
of Diseases.
I have to categorize this
patient's complaints, symptoms,
signs.
Otherwise, the
visit doesn't count.
CPT codes, Current
Procedural Terminology--
that's what counts
in health care today.
If you want to learn what's
most worth caring about,
you need to spend some
time in situations that
draw your attention elsewhere.
Because it's only in a
deficit of what counts most
that I think we can
see most clearly what
really counts for the most.
So I come to you not as an
emissary of a profession that
is thriving.
In many respects,
we're at the pinnacle
of the history of medicine.
In terms of the
diagnostic tests we do,
the therapies we can
prescribe, our understanding
of the anatomy, physiology,
pathology, pathophysiology
of human health
and disease, we've
never risen to this level.
But at the very
same moment, we're
at perhaps unprecedented risk
of losing the human thread
in medicine, attending
to things that
are secondary at the expense
of those that are primary.
So I would encourage you, if
you're contemplating a career
in the health professions, to
get as good a liberal education
as you can.
And then bring that education
as a form of advocacy
beginning day one
of medical school
and carrying right through your
undergraduate medical education
and into residency
and fellowship.
We desperately
need people who can
see what matters
most, who realize
that not everything that can
be counted really counts,
and who realize that
some of the things we
spend a lot of time counting
don't really count for much.
So never, at least
in my lifetime,
has the need for liberally
educated people in the health
professions been greater.
So that's, in a way, a call
to arms, or at least a call
to action.
You can actually not only
care for your patients,
but you can diagnose
and administer therapy
to the profession
of medicine itself,
which is not in the best
of health in some respects.
But by showing us what medicine
looks like at its best,
you can help us reconnect with
the core of medical excellence.
Thanks again for your question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you so much for
coming out to speak to us.
For someone who is planning
to go into the medical field
and dealing with patients no
matter what-- whether it's
psychological, whether
it's physical-- how would
you suggest that they
best prepare themselves
to face every patient with
the same intentionality
and care as they
did the last one,
as it can get kind of exhausting
to hear again and again,
and you're bearing
someone else's burdens.
RICHARD B. GUNDERMAN: Now,
that's a terrific problem.
Physicians and health
professionals, in general,
can burn out.
You can only work so many
hours a day, only work
at a certain pace.
But I think one
reason that we face
a challenge of
burnout in health care
today is because sometimes
we are encouraged or perhaps
forced to practice in
ways that prevent us
from caring for patients
to the best of our ability.
One of the most demoralizing
things that can happen to you
is to have a job you care about
deeply and then be deprived
of the opportunity
to do it well.
So I don't claim to have
a panacea, a cure-all
that we can administer
in this case.
But I can imagine somebody,
before they enter the room
with a patient, pausing
for a few seconds,
perhaps to offer a prayer,
perhaps to reorient
and recalibrate to what
this is really all about.
In the hustle and
bustle, sometimes we
can get disoriented.
I think that disorientation
is a big part
of people getting discouraged
and exhausted in medicine.
And you can be
one of the people.
None of us is perfect.
There's no foolproof solution.
But you can be one
of the people who
pauses to recall what
this is really all
about before every
patient encounter.
And I firmly believe that
can make a real difference,
not only over the course
of a day of practice,
but over the course of
a career of practice.
Thank you.
ANNA KATE HICKS: We have
time for one more question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for your talk.
So during this time
of COVID, there
is a greater emphasis on
separating the elderly
from the outside
for their protection
and for their safety.
Obviously, this contributes to
a greater amount of loneliness.
Is there a relationship between
the sickness and loneliness?
Are we doing more harm
than good by separating
the elderly from contact with
their loved ones or family?
RICHARD B. GUNDERMAN:
It's a great question.
I may have this slightly wrong,
but former US Surgeon General
Vivek Murthy published
a book, I think in 2018,
called The Epidemic
of Loneliness.
He basically presented
evidence that being lonely
may be about as
bad for your health
as smoking 15 cigarettes a day.
That's a pretty serious
insult to your health.
I do not think that captures
the damage done by loneliness.
To say it decreases
our life expectancy
or increases the number
of days lost from work
only scratches the surface
of a much deeper reality.
But there is a recognition
that loneliness
is bad for human beings.
After the World Wars
there were large numbers
of orphans in Europe, and they
were placed in institutions.
You know, their
diapers were changed.
They were fed regularly.
The ambient
temperature was right.
But in many cases, they not
only didn't grow and develop
normally, but actually
withered away.
And for a time, that syndrome
was referred to as hospitalism.
Today we call it
failure to thrive.
But the lesson there is
we human beings don't just
need nutrients, adequate
hydration, sanitation
or hygiene.
We also need human contact,
by which I mean in part touch.
We human beings need to
touch and be touched.
And, because of COVID, there
are nursing home residents
around the country
who at points have
been confined to their
rooms for periods of time
as long as months.
And no visitors were
allowed in the facility.
We can do some things
with tablet computers,
[LAUGHS] various video
conferencing software.
But I think there's, in the end,
no substitute for human touch.
And I don't pretend to
have a simple solution.
But we must make sure when
we're thinking about things
like death rates, number of
years of lives lost, that we're
also thinking about
what life really means,
what it takes to
come fully to life,
at least to the extent
we can as human beings.
And I think part of
that is human contact.
And that's actually a role that
you could play to some degree.
You may know somebody in your
family, from your neighborhood,
perhaps here in
this town, perhaps
on this campus, who's lonely.
And each of us has
it within our power
to reach out to one
such person and let
them know we're thinking
about them, maybe
even to schedule a
conversation, if possible,
perhaps even a visit.
You do not need a
bachelor's degree or an MD
Or a residency certification to
reach out to people to let them
know you're thinking
about them, to let them
know that you care about them.
That's within the
range of competence
of every single person
in this theater.
And it's a responsibility
and an opportunity
I would encourage you
to take seriously.
If you start doing that now--
if you go to nursing school or
dental school or medical school
or what have you, you will
bring much better habits--
habits of perception,
of understanding,
habits of the heart--
than some of the rest of us
did when we buffed up our GPAs
and maxed out our medical
college admission test scores.
Those things are good, but
they're not what matters most.
And if you're one
of the people who
sees what matters most and has
developed habits of reaching
out to people to tend
what matters most,
you can make very
significant contributions
to the healing professions.
ANNA KATE HICKS: Please join
me in thanking Dr. Gunderman.
[APPLAUSE]